[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday coming up a mammoth undertaking
in the field of genetics how a team of
researchers is trying to bring an
ancient creature back to life and open
the door to more remarkable revivals and
sin city lights up just hours ago Las
Vegas allowed the sale of recreational
marijuana well look at how the city is
preparing for the flood of new business
and legal issues that's ahead but we
start this half-hour with large protests
taking place in Hong Kong against the
Chinese government today is the 20th
anniversary of Britain's handover of its
former colony to China at the end of a
99 year lease been Tracy's in Hong Kong
this morning with more on how people
there feel their freedoms aren't under
threat good morning this city is the
only place in China where you can openly
protest against the government and
that's because when Hong Kong was handed
back from Great Britain it retained most
of the freedoms that it had but now a
lot of people here feel those freedoms
are slipping away
thousands of people filled parts of
downtown Hong Kong Saturday demanding
that the Chinese government respect the
city's special status and the rights
that come with it changing dong-gwon
much of the anger is directed at Chinese
President Xi Jinping who swore in Hong
Kong's new chief executive today Carrie
Lam is widely seen as someone who will
defer to Beijing this is President Xi's
first trip to Hong Kong since taking
office five years ago and the Chinese
government is clearly trying to show its
strength while celebrating the handover
anniversary we don't celebrate we mourn
jason Inge is a lawyer and author
he says Hong Kongers worried China is
undermining the agreement it made when
Britain returned the city in 1997 known
as one country two systems' Hong Kong is
part of China but retains a high level
of autonomy and rights such as freedom
of speech and an independent judiciary
the hope at the time was at this city of
seven million people would help make the
rest of China more open and free do you
think China is becoming more like Hong
Kong or as Hong Kong becoming more like
China this general sense that China will
slowly democratize in Hong Kong would
benefit from that seems to be a pipe
dream and in the past you know five or
six years we have seen really an
acceleration of China's political agenda
on Hong Kong Beijing is tightening its
grip it recently blocked
pro-independence lawmakers from taking
office and abducted five publishers who
sold books critical of the Chinese
government Lam Winkie was detained for
eight months and says he was forced to
sign a confession he says if the Chinese
government does not follow Hong Kong's
Constitution the city will have no
choice but to push for independence most
people here don't believe China would
ever allow Hong Kong to be truly
independent but protests like this have
soared more than 200 percent in the past
decade because people here fear their
way of life is
ataque 20 year old activist Joshua Wong
was arrested this week at a protest he
led opposition to so-called patriotic
education in Hong Kong schools and was
part of the massive protests that shut
down large parts of the city in 2014
this 20th anniversary is being called a
celebration by some how does it feel to
you it's not the time for celebration
it's time for demonstration they have
determined to be one country one system
we hope to maintain democracy and ask
for autonomy but in his speech before he
left Hong Kong Chinese President Xi
Jingping gave a pretty stern warning
he said that any challenge to China's
sovereignty or the central government's
authority crosses a red line and won't
be tolerated Anthony and Tracy in Hong
Kong thanks Ben